[Music]
in happiest place ruined me no Oh Scooby
Disney balloons yeah
submitted by what up David [ __ ] David
thank you wherever you are I like you do
someone tweeted about a breakup that
went terribly wrong at Disney World and
it went viral what I want to go to
Disney World
wait till you see on a ride or even of
the contrast Oh pretty funny contrast
like it's going to add more to your why
the [ __ ] okay okay this girl she ended
up tweeting like in her notes
she wrote out this entire story then she
screenshotted it she was like sitting
next to the couple in the bench and she
was like - oh goddess what happened
she'll tell you okay okay okay here we
go
so Ben and I were leaving VHS Esther and
TASMAC and the park was all over so it
was a big crowd of us streaming out the
front gates towards the bus after
crossing through the front gates Ben and
I along with a group of 30 plus people
around us notice this woman in her late
teens / early twenties just sobbing hey
ugly crying this guy trailing behind her
kept trying to touch her shoulder to
sort of half-assed comfort her come on
okay oh man I'm sorry just [ __ ]
around your life I don't want to do this
but like a lot more [ __ ] yeah right
I bet she's doing that shoulder thing
you know when they touch me again know
me again come on you can don't you don't
do this right now Meegan no mind
everything is the [ __ ] we used like like
a little kid in the store
think try to grab me mini noodle out
yeah you noodle s yeah I do that all the
time
you do yes because that's my my
strengths because I don't have strength
so that's how I get out what's your
barbecue is the noodle out but she's
gotten up and screamed stop touching me
Oh first thought was that this guy was
harassing her so we spend me area
onlookers beat the [ __ ] out of him no
questions asked
beat the plug either haha we'll find out
what's going on later
that now she just keeps yelling at him
and sobbing he keeps saying things like
baby baby it'll be okay
then she turns around on her heel and
screamed at him I can't believe you blew
me out too busy road to break up with me
the crowd goes mmm birthday anniversary
another sympathetic a sympathetic crowd
oh and you planned it out weeks ahead of
time a really loud crowd Oh an expense a
break oh yeah we would just got arrested
just like one person takes us on one
person is pulled them apart under one
thing more
yeah so guy turns and looks at all of us
and gets embarrassed she goes back to
sobbing at this point we again the whole
crowd of us our half walking to the
buses have following them and watching
the show he starts rubbing her back as
she was walking she keeps saying things
like I thought we were forever I thought
you were going super bone oh I can't
believe this is happening
and so on I love this godless as they
walk she's calming down and she says
well we can talk about this we can talk
about it and he says sure baby yeah baby
stuff like that looks like the show's
over then she splits off to go get into
the all-stars bus line which is like a
resort and boyfriend have hugs her and
keeps walking she says wait where are
you going we're gonna go home prior to
getting you want to comb it just like
one laughs I'm going to a new girlfriend
Yeah right if I go through get up dull
pineapple day before park closes
doughnut Yeah right
do you own one always like either you
gotta buy your own though because like
we're broken up I don't own anything
she's like a district was expensive good
you out here so and you stopped looks at
her and says well baby I got my own room
she screams what and tears
ass out of line and screams where she
starts saying maybe you can keep the
other room
also pay for it I'll still pay for the
trip what keep the other room what the
hell and she's just screaming over and
over where are you going where are you
going and finally he lets the bomb drop
I got another room at the Grand
Floridian I go with this because I don't
really know the resources all that well
the All Stars is kind of like a value or
preferred ward
yeah yeah and then the Grand Floridian
it's like the deluxe like the moat my
god the first one Circus Circus and
Bellagio right yes pretty much why did
he do that is so [ __ ] Pamela then we
could sit she continues as soon as he
says he got the room at the grand flow
and was sending her to the all-stars the
entire crowd that was pretending to not
be listening just gasp and she's crying
again hysterically he's telling her to
calm down she keeps asking why he
brought her to Disney just a dumper and
he says half to the crowd have to us I
kid you not
well I thought I know Disney is your
favorite place in the world I thought
that would make this easier for you
social she's ugly crying he's talking
about how she has a whole week to do
whatever she wants a Disney by herself
he dumped her at the start of their
vacation Oh oh my god no no that's not
her favorite lands anymore I had a whole
week to like [ __ ] hang out disney by
herself
he has great intentions oh and she whips
out her phone and screams I'm calling a
cab I'm staying at the Grand Floridian
you leave me alone and start power
walking to the taxi area while screaming
scream sobbing into the phone she needs
a cab he's trailing after yelling she
can't because people are waiting for him
there more crying
by then the can I help you Disney cast
member Brigade and security arrived it
was the most amazing awful thing I ever
saw it Disney oh my god so this is a guy
who was raised with this thing where
it's like it's like it's honorable it's
not honorable to break up with a chick
over the phone or text again there are
no long-distance relationships we've had
this chick that I want a buck I can't
[ __ ] her yet I'm going to fly my
soon-to-be ex girlfriend out break up
with her at the start of my vacation
with my new girlfriend and then I'll be
in the clear morally I guarantee that's
what's up and she gets to enjoy Disney
World
yeah I'm so good guy that's [ __ ]
great insane dude something with snappin
E and I would go to whoever he's beating
and I would just start beating us at
everyone and I wouldn't I would black
out like I would see red and I would
whisper culturable
I just can't be held responsible for
what happens after that's too much work
that's so much I just done
I don't think of working bye
yeah nobody's honourable yeah yes good
you cares about her yeah yeah he thinks
it's [ __ ] made to break up over phone
or or whatever I agree with that what is
the complete opposite he was like
walking ruin do ya ever those his real
attention yeah because it's really like
you been mean to me for the last three
years
ah see move is just before Disney get
her out with the carrot of this you take
her to like you know I don't know what
you know when you're driving on the
freeway forever like 500 mile road trip
and like I'm like mile marker [ __ ]
323 this is like New York meteor crater
or some [ __ ] you know I mean like it's
like some kind of landmark yeah some
shitty ass [ __ ] side bar thing
biggest ball of yarn you take her there
you take a picture with her and you're
like hands don't think it's working out
and I'm going to grant flurry thing it's
going to be [ __ ] a great time no
saying but then at least you did the
honorable thing like you're talking
about I mean like face to face like yeah
I agree with you like I would prefer if
I do would tell me like hey I'm not
interested in dating you or Ellen you
know if we've been seeing each other for
a while I'd rather haven't um like can
we meet up hey I have dinner while I
tell you how much it's not going to work
out oh my god violently I mean to plan a
whole vacation and to dump at the
beginning that is terrible but this cat
didn't plan a vacation for him and her
he planned a vacation for him and his
knee
a chicken or whatever her brother or
month yeah [ __ ] yeah but and then now he
things are doing the honorable thing
but let me her stay there but he gets
his conscience quick I mean you could
have broken up with her before the trip
yeah I mean I don't know if there was
long distance I'm assuming that they
flew together to go there I think this
guy's know is [ __ ]
honestly I think this story's great you
spent a lot of money doing this um would
you do it just happen to you come here I
would wait till after Fantasmic like
what exactly did I think I'm so like
[ __ ] unemotionally this or just just
emotionally detached that I think I'd be
like cool oh I'm the so opposite I might
be torn and sighs I'd like school as
though oh I'm like so emotionally
invested if I'm like if I'm with
somebody like it's all it's always like
forever until it's not like it's like
we're like you're the only person right
and so if if I'm not loyal and they do
me like that all over like oh poor
people get rekt you go get something
feel so bad for you you leave it like
that's why we're getting married
get him he knows walk it with a bar -
yeah you know how to open but you know
what if someone was gonna break up with
me because I've been you know it's
happened before I rather take this
option I'd rather be crying at
Disneyland cuz I mean itself is better
than right better than quite at home
it's a great place to cry no one's wrong
my cat's not at you because after I get
that turkey leg in that churro it's
going to change my leave was not about
the chair on the turkey legs in the
corner I don't like foods like that on
top of that I'm a boss I'll find [ __ ]
anywhere I'm sorry go back to that Joe
that you've talked about in the past
where like you just were so heartbroken
over this one girl let's say like well I
had to do that in my room with the
money and no playthings and fun I mean
I'm crying and dizzy like and you're
like at the haunted house and there's a
ghost in your lap yes yeah right it
would I would have made my day a little
bit better I think I'm with John for
sure I would have been better but I
think I would be more angry at the fact
that they ruined something I love so
much
yeah I can't walk around seeing people
being happy where you put the good
intention of them like they do they
won't know I'll let you down yeah I'd be
like this I can't believe I was with the
[ __ ] [ __ ] for I know yeah he's
[ __ ] stupid I don't think there was a
good invention here I think he did for
himself obviously I was so so mind
[ __ ]
I was just feel so [ __ ] with like I
was like there's no way someone could
have been this stupid alright I think I
might see it that way if he would have
originally booked the deluxe resort yeah
for her yeah the cheap one yeah okay
yeah
have you ever have you ever stayed at
the Ulster no I never
I wasn't saying that's what we're saying
that he didn't have you but she's like
oh he's like a rough it for one night
there that's it when the grand [ __ ]
Floridian I would follow him he was I
know hey guys thanks for watching our
last episode did you love it I know you
did so make sure to give this video a
big thumbs up and to watch more videos
you can watch em up here
[Music]